écoute us 13h heure même temps très
stressé parce que voilà j'ai envie de
donner toujours le max au public et le
public voilà c'est choisir c'est le
public un jour il est là il ya un autre
jour
c'est public si il est une fidélité
incroyable écoute un méchant d'ailleurs
merci au public de faire que cette
émission existe depuis maintenant 12 ans
non mais c'est fou ça c'est fait c'est
fou c'est fou avec des gens
c'est un miracle
l'acsta miracle s'est passé la soirée
monnaies mais on savait tu vois ça mais
moi j'étais avec lui dis ouais il a un
truc en plus l'on a réussi avec des
trucs au monde
c'est comme si tu vois jan map est foutu
la merde ou non nous c'est comme si un
gars il met toutes les balles à côté de
l'école nouvelle fabrique de fruits mais
tous les malades et dans les tribunes et
rate un penalty que non je veux ce gars
je veux ce gars je veux ce gars c'est un
truc de fou c'est vrai tant messi sakifo
bravo à vous
ça nous rappelle qu'en maths - plus - ça
fait plus oublier jamais chasser l'adage
cette émission
tu viens de voir parce que tu es de
retour sur canal plus avec le flambeau
les aventuriers de chupa capra sachez
que c'est une merveille j'avais adoré la
première durant leur flamme kabala qui
était une cité ne parle des majors
s'étaient culte je pense pour moi et je
le redis je pense que c'est au dessus
chez curé qui l'ont vu comme moi ici
pour moi c'est encore au dessus c'est
une énorme dar k voilà je vous dis on va
regarder la bande annonce et on aura
droit à trois épisodes par soirée tous
les lundis avec un casting de malades
jérôme commandeur et que jean bracci rom
si tu nous regardes bravo
pour tout ce que tu fais pour le cinéma
français
géraldine nakache que j'embrasse
géraldine nakache tesson mono aux colons
ouais c'est faux ça et je les ai vus
partira aussi comme ça toi c'est fou
c'est fou ça gérard darmon que
j'embrasse mon girard thiam for a day lé
clark au boulot ce que j'adore c'est une
merveille voilà c'est après voilà plein
de jolies arcadia ramzy j'aime bien
parce que je suis venu à toulon après
voilà j'ai bien et il ya bien sûr il ya
les labertit
voilà la queen patronne qu'elle sera
peut-être avec nous on facetime dans un
sens c'est pas mal hein juste comme elle
a un nokia 32 10
faire livrer un bail voilà elle va le
recevoir dans quelques instants les
médias qu'à 9 oui nous les nous quand on
est bloqué ce à clermont ferrand et le
festival de cannes voilà donc mais on
aura peut-être en fait cette annonce à
l'instant pour l'instant on regarde la
bande annonce et c'est ce soir dès ce
soir et ce soir ça fait du bien en ce
moment là on a là on est là les gars on
n'entend que des rats sera bien un gala
bilco vide maintenant ils ont trouvé un
nouveau gaal un singe chine
jusqu'à quand frère n'est que tu touches
un animal faire tu crois que tu vois que
tu n'as pas hésité avec moyen chez hergé
crucial à moins que truc a laissé plus
c'est un truc d'hommes et on y voit des
maladies faire tu te sinotruk style
mucha ça
sert à quoi le nom mais je te dis non
cas là il faut qu'il faut se détendre
sans rigoler voilà un nid comme bouc
regardez
vous allez devoir survivre pendant 38
jours
sans rien
sûr que c'est là parce qu'il n'y a pas
de vie d'un chien mal criant on va te
construire nous mêmes tout construire
avec trois ânes nos mains peut-être
devront dépasser la fin on clame lada il
n'y a pas de déjeuner ni de devinez quoi
la fatigue a bien dormi plutôt bien oui
les trahisons évidemment que je voulais
travailler
l'air pour la ford
seul de ses 14 aventuriers succédera
même pierre emporté
150 euros une somme folle rien
n'empêchera gagné 450 euros baker et
fait que commencer on est trop long ted
vomir c'est le seul moyen de faire du
poids à pinon
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel
ça y est ce sera en clair ce soir sur
canal+ canal+ sa famille c'est la
famille clair le premier bien sûr ça
ferait ritchie
[Musique]
je veux kg hockey et ça te remercier max
inch'allah merci merci mais la voilà
maxime qui roulent mais on en clair ce
soir ou qu'est ce que tu veux non moi
j'avais adoré la ferme ce que tu
cherches ici dans cette recherche quoi
faire remarquer
j'avais adoré la flamme j'ai encore plus
adoré le flambeau on rit tout le temps
les nouveaux personnages sont
exceptionnels là complotistes elle est
magnifique
le complotisme ce que je pense à notre
personnage l'autre mes personnages avec
ses chiens au début moi j'ai une
question si vous deviez faire une saison
3 est ce qu'il ya un autre programme qui
vous inspire well et mollo déjà l'idée
déjà fait celui-là
en bref c'est pas à tête la star ac ça
va revenir en irak je crois que c'est ça
c'est pour vous dire un truc de malade
et j'en vois qui fait ça déjà arrivé et
on prend les matches les uns après les
autres et on verra je suis d'accord il
appelle moi tout à pécho une mode tu
veux déjà savoir que tu m'as
pécheresse ont décollé calme-toi frérot
oui malheureusement d'arrêt mais
jonathan cohen alias djoko vous êtes
l'homme le plus drôle de france ces gens
là qui dit ce sont mes deux filles des
mères toute la famille enfin les enfants
les jeunes les ados vous vénèrent ils
connaissent évidemment toutes les
punchline de la flamme le flambeau il
attendait avec impatience parce que
c'est trash c'est méchant c'est corrosif
c'est tout ce qu'on aime c'est tout ce
qu'on n'ose plus aujourd'hui forcément
dire c'est politiquement incorrect
hand-ball hausse mais gare au loup vous
êtes juste fabuleux et franchement il
est très bien en fait l'acquisition en
fin d'émission en fait on aimerait
pouvoir en parler comme ça parce que
finalement vous vous en parlait comme un
on aimerait pouvoir en parler on essaie
voilà c'est certainement en ça fait du
bien parce que koh lanta jumeaux car le
cul aux ménages
dis donc ça me fait du bien de voir ça
lâche personnages
et j'adore crétins magnifique un crétin
manas et nous les crétins ça nous
connaît un
on
connaît non mais alors joué qu un
extrait comme dans koh lanta dans le
flambeau le plus important sur le camp
c'est la nourriture et mais avec un mec
comme l'arc ça peut parfois être
compliqué regarder
devant
[Applaudissements]
et madame simone nord non non non je
vais faire mieux que ça
et tu peux faire pour adam et on aurait
pu les manger on aurait pu les manger
and as déjà entendu parler des bananes
plantain bah oui oui qu'elle pousse
comment les bananes plantains en les
mangeant ben non en les plantant douce
on nous
[Applaudissements]
la vie sauve et l'embarras causé mister
john lambert et jonathan lambert on va
avoir deux autres extraits non enfin un
autre extrait dans un instant justesse
que leïla bekhti est avec nous leïla est
taillée on a peint
merci d'être là ma chérie tu sais que je
t'aime
hlm trop je te lawrence et basse assez
assez assez c'est la patronne c'est
l'avait sauvé chéri d'amour
chez mula quand je te vois dit moi quand
je vois des quand je vois des gens en
comme ça en fait j'ai l'impression de
revenir à l'époque du coït frère tiens
bon on est confiné je suis aura sera
totale j'ai l'impression que leïla
bekhti chez un docteur oui madame mais
qui est ce que vous êtes en mesure de
nous dire
quand est ce qu'on aura les premiers
vaccins c'est pas grave ça j'avais plus
l'habitude d'avoir déjanté pacte est
bloquée à cannes - chérie ça va
bloquer axial mais
voilà je veux dire alors des parfums la
leçon n'est pas où on va pas te mentir
c'est pas non plus le meilleur sont
connus sur ces 15 dernières années
sur la petite lucarne on a fait mieux
leila juteux voulais te dire qu'on
t'aime que tu es formidable dans le
flambant tu es toujours belle et si
belle mort et que tu sais que tu sais
comme tu content pour moi elle a tout
bon c'était un plaisir de te parler
merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était à rémy sachez c'est à sa ca ca
technologies de la mauricie on vit en
2000 ballmer
duplex au festin satellite images c'est
super bien on sait pas où ça balaye la
wii mais la france on adore parce que
c'est un nouveau concept
c'est un nouveau concept extraordinaire
c'est à dire que tu es là tu vois et on
est content de voir la personne sony et
on imagine tu penses que tu peux penser
ce que tu peux dire c'est un nouveau
concept de l'interview que j'aime
énormément et je vais certainement
d'ailleurs le lancer j'ai certainement
faire un format là dessus il lie la
honte m
si
l'arc
change d'opérateur lila
leïla ont été toi à sion d'amour qu'est
ce que t'en j'ai entendu déclaration
d'amour déclaration d'amour tu veux
faire une déclaration assis à moi
alors j'ai rasin a dit
leila on voulait faire une déclaration
d'amour à jonathan non c'est réussi toi
je pense non pour toi ok de ce que j'ai
entendu c'est de dire on dirait quand on
est vous savez le bescherelle quand il
ya des trucs à trous mais tu dois
remplacer le verbe entre parenthèses là
on sait que c'est le verbe aimer non
c'est pas mon prix
et la
mairie
grâce à
lui seul et d'amour et bravo pour ce
duplex je pense que tu te restera lente
et images télé ça
un mot sur quatre
c'est de jouer au hameau sur certaines
vous chez vous de découvrir que monsieur
que notre invité veut nous dire c'est
parti on joue tout de suite pour
connaître en place
merci saluant l'attitude jouer h tentant
pas quand tu parles
si vous voulez jouer avec notre
attention
sur notre compte twitter et bien sûr il
ya des dragibus et gagner on va regarder
un deuxième extrait on a le son
notre respect important c'est bien sûr
la stratégie et là vous allez voir un
extrait avec jonathan lambert jonathan
cohen et ramzy est d'ailleurs jean roy
jonathan qu'il devait venir ah ouais là
pas plus mon autonomie d'abc bouchehr
regarder
les
jeux derrière toi
la chauffeur noir
je n'ai rien toi
je t'envoie la wii mettez pas derrière
ouais t'as raison donnée mais je pars
toi
ballet j'entends encore texan mark le
manipulateur
alors les filles j'ai trouvé de l'eau
je l'attends qu elle à ne pas manquer
dès ce soir dès ce soir ce sera en clair
sur canal+ le flambeau avec mon jonathan
que j'aime qui est exceptionnel de deux
mondes michel bientôt j'aime bien te
voir et c'est toujours vrai alors c'est
qu'on a été voir l'équipe du flambeau en
fin mai et qui pourra les voir l'équipe
du flan monetel à votre rencontre lors
de l'avant-première vous a proposé des
questions intimes et si vous n'aviez pas
la réponse à nous donner il fallait en
balancer une sur moi regarde
[Musique]
à mal le jeu pas match a déjà posé nue
dans un magazine
mais par contre cyril lui je peux vous
dire qu'il a posé nue dans le figaro les
plus vendus je le hais censure et le
lendemain je revenais au figaro à
l'époque je fais service volée au
paraguay et au service de tous et des
épices des décès annoncés est ce que
c'est vrai que tu chine souvent en dm
sur un stade
non le revanche cyril oui
est ce que tu as déjà eu recours à la
chirurgie esthétique
je suis navré de vous décevoir je n'ai
pas eu recours je sais que j'allais dire
pas encore en revanche cyril et parce
que j'avais de lui dernièrement j'ai eu
du mal à le saluer ce n'est pas reconnu
c'est vrai il avait un côté comme ça
j'ai dit c'est du christ et de chavannes
bon je comprends qu'il l'ait fait mais
en même temps c'est un paul huchon raté
quand même c'est ce que je
tenais tout celle du basson est ce que
tu as déjà eu une relation intime avec
jonathan cohen on a tourné en corse pour
le flambeau et c'est vrai que cyril
revenus est venue de trois fois et ont
pensé qu' il avait son lot
est ce que tu as une particularité
physique qui pourrait repousser
certaines personnes j'étais très loose
orteils et cyril lente apparu lui mettre
un petit coup dans le dos photo peut
être mignon
est-ce que vous avez un toc qui vous
gâchent la vie
la nourriture ça me gâche la vie si on
me dit c'est les meilleures frites vas-y
je suis prête à faire 2h45 de voiture et
si les frites elles n'étaient pas fine
comme on m'avait dit qu'elle était finie
je peux avoir les larmes aux yeux
et bien moi je pense que cyril il
préfère pas manger kaufmann
tirent une fois
c'est exact mais moi je peux peut-être
les communes isolées je pense qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas douter - ciel c'est ça
son gros problème et de la bouffe
là on apprend
[Musique]
j'attends
gendarmes faisaient bien entendu et 6
ans géraldine nakache leïla bekhti adel
j'adore aussi lent jérôme commandeur son
bébé un vrai j'oubliais personne ce que
quand tu oublié qu'après la caisse et
aline et non mais je te parle là oui
alain gilles andrier bien sûr là sur le
gars est là sinon le gat appel après
ouais pourquoi pas d'y et
watts exact trois sites à problèmes avec
moi je veux que tu me le disent ils
moi j'ai toujours été derrière toi quoi
tu vois